my best friend died in arms right there
you know that was when things got real
crazy for me you know
it was hard to accept his death i mean
really we were like this you know what
i'm saying
very popular oh you grew up where
um i grew up in this actually i was born
in uh linwood i grew up in watts for a
little bit yeah right by the watts
towers um
my whole family's from watts actually um
[Music]
my mom
okay here it goes i gotta tell you the
whole thing let me get stuff from the
beginning so anyway
i was conceived actually down here skid
row because my mom was a prostitute
really yes
and heroin addict
um
and she came out here she met my my dad
which was uh he was a gang member out
here big time drug dealer so she knows
she got with him for that she actually
stayed around here somewhere though
so i believe i was conceived down here
yeah all the all the hookers around
agatha which is yes well my mom you know
sorry to say was one of them yeah and uh
also she's uh
she was a heroin addict she did anything
anything in the book
um so
they met down here
i was born uh july 17 1980 um in linwood
jail or lynwood hospital because my mom
was already
in jail when she had me
um
so after that i was lucky enough to get
adopted by my grandparents you know
which were pretty decent people except
for
i mean my grandma
she was not raging alcoholic she beat us
you know
but um her
boyfriend was a white dude you know
military legit person
so i kind of had that
you know that little little balance kind
of you know growing up
but uh anyhow we lived in southgate
watts until one day they got in a fight
my grandma wanted to take me from my dad
obviously
so one night we two in the morning she
took me and my brother's history and
took off you know
she she thought she was moving us to a
better place she was sidious whittier i
don't know if you heard that yeah
whittier is great
people know this and it is great
what they don't know is there's a big
big gang issue out there
and murders and stuff like that
kidnappings i mean the worst of the
worst you know
i guess they migrated from the east side
there yeah um so we've moved there i met
this kid named josh you know best
friends first dude i smoke weed with
you know i'm saying
uh he was adopted like me
so uh i looked up to the kid
he basically uh was my role model
out there so i try to be like josh hung
out with josh every day you know
josh had emotional issues because he was
raped by his parents you know what i'm
saying
um
i kind of went through the same thing so
we kind of had a little
almost like a bond because of it because
we both had been through something like
that
so we met we were little but uh
the way he grew up was just a whole
different way that i had knew at first
so
once i started hanging out with josh i
went from
a normal little kid to uh
stealing motorcycles you know i'm
talking the age of nine breaking out my
window to go roll the motorcycle up the
street we didn't know how to ride
and
we
uh
up getting from a gang together you know
uh age 11
i got from my gang which was a bad
mistake
um
i think it was uh four years into that
my best friend died in my arms he got
shot
by also it was it was it was kind of
crazy because it was a kid that we
actually grew up with that turned into
and got to another game but we're all
family you know yeah and uh one day we
went to his house to disrespect him we
tagged on us while we were little kids
as we were walking away he came out with
a gun and he was like
crying you know because we've been
harassing them harassing them for a
while
you know because in our neighborhood we
used to get people out if they didn't
like them you get me
so anyway we go we tag on the jews while
he comes out with his dad's 45 he's
crying screaming telling us i should
shoot you kill you
we're looking at my buddies like man
you're a [ __ ] bro what do you do with
that you know you didn't do nothing with
that
he goes man put that [ __ ] away for i
[ __ ] you up you know
you know okay goes dude [ __ ] you dude i
should [ __ ] he's he's trying to hype
himself up nothing happens with my
friend josh is mad he's like you know
what
[ __ ] you and he starts to run at the
kids you know to get him the last second
he got out of scaredness he pulls his
gun up
my buddy grabbed it try to wrestle him
and that's when i heard the six shots he
shot him six times point blank range in
the stomach
you know then he went to a shock he ran
inside got his parents which were gang
related to
um they came out and said we should have
did what we did and basically uh
my best friend died in arms right there
you know that was when things got real
crazy for me you know
it was hard to accept his death i mean
we really were like this you know what
i'm saying
and we both run from our parents because
they're alcoholics and they beat us
um
so basically after that i was basically
a street kid you know
and um
just went through a lot of things i've
been kidnapped in my time
by my like i've had that my enemies
kidnapped me
for two days beating me killed two of my
friends in front of me made me watch you
know
um
i was at the age of like 16 i went
through that
i had accepted death you know but um
it's kind of hard to accept that i don't
know you've been in there at that point
but um
to realize you're gonna die
and accept it and have people putting
guns in your mouth and pillows on your
head and stabbing your friends making
you watch
you know it'll do a thing or two to your
head you know what i'm saying sure
so um
yeah basically i got kidnapped they
broke in our drug house and they took us
hostage
the guy who took this hostage was my
best friend
one of my best friends
he ended up doing a six-year prison term
right
while he was in prison for six years i
got some guy one of my other best
friends in in my neighborhood
he ended up being with that guy's
girlfriend right so this guy thinks i
hooked him up
excuse me
long story short
i introduced them
they fell in love the dude was doing six
years we all lied to his face right six
years that's where he until he finally
came out
and um
on the phone he played me he said you
know we're good dude just you know i
want to find out what this guy is that
you know i'm kind of mad at you but
we're good
so i'll be seeing you on this day anyway
he lied about the day
came i guess he got out six days earlier
so when all we know is we hear a pound
on the door right it's a direct pad that
world in my neighborhood we're singing
drugs out of i'm like
he was 23. my my other two buddies were
younger than me
as we hear the pound i'm like it's kind
of weird i go to licked up through the
blinds
the girl that was with us that was
playing you know like she liked that she
was actually setting this up
so this is one of the scariest times
like
i mean hands down scariest things i ever
went through brother
right when i look out the window and i
see nothing but armed dudes out there
waiting to come in
i look at her scream don't don't don't
don't unlock the door and she just
smiles at me unlocks the door dude next
you know they break the door boom m16 in
my face crack
you know
telling us we're dead right there
they're streaming at us i mean
emotionally i was just
losing it
um
a couple of the homies tried to run they
automatically shot them
they had to be at least 20 people deep
right
so they shot them
they were gonna leave me
but the person they were looking for
wasn't there so what they wanted to do
was uh
they said [ __ ] tie them up they tied
us up
threw us in the back of the trunk of the
car out where i come from nobody the
neighbors don't say nothing about
nothing they don't want no involvement
so
basically if we shoot somebody they
don't they will not say a word out there
they're scared they we used to be scared
now it's to the point to where we're
kind of like protection for them you
understand
and um
so basically uh
yeah they broke in there they they they
got us
i i pretty much when i seen the gun
when i first kicked the door i thought i
was dead instantly you know
and uh
so they took us they they tied us up
there they they pulled their cars in
they just threw us in the trunk and um
pretty much tortured us tortured us for
two days they wanted us to give up our
other friend the guy who got his wife
pregnant
so basically he came at me
and he's a you know gun down my mouth
telling me he loves me
and he doesn't he doesn't want to have
to do this he doesn't want to kill me
but
i heard him
i hooked up his wife you know so the
guy's mad
he wants me to call my buddy
he says he's gonna kill all three of us
right there
if i don't make the phone call
and uh
send my other friend up so he'll die you
know what i'm saying so
i told him pretty much [ __ ] you spin in
his face
and so they they hot tied us took us
had us in a motel for two days uh pretty
much beat us
pulled a couple of nose out of our our
sockets you know
uh he would stick a knife in our legs
pretty slow he was torturing us pretty
much he wanted us to give up my other
friend
which we all didn't um put nails out of
your way he pulled our nose out of our
hands oh fingernails yeah our
fingernails that's gotta hurt
yeah it was one of the worst things i
mean he tried he was trying to break us
he wanted us to say what he wanted he
wanted to humiliate us
um i'm from city of whittier like
southeast la out there like you know
it's pretty crazy out there you know
people wouldn't think it is but at night
it's a whole different world you know
what i'm saying
and anyway
once your name goes uh you know kind of
weak or you show you know trust me out
there they go and they'll kill you
someone will
so uh basically he wanted me to bow down
and say what he wanted what she didn't
ever got i told you i'd rather die
with my pride than have you um
you know
make me turn myself my buddy in
for
my life you know what i'm saying if
you're gonna kill me kill me
which the guy wasn't doing so i kind of
had a feeling that he wasn't in the
first place obviously he didn't well he
ended up killing my two best friends my
other friends in front of me stoner he
stabbed me to death made me watch
my other buddy you know and uh
let me go he dropped me off in my
neighborhood kicked me out the car
um my homeboy seen me and they i was so
bad they they both our muslim were
either crying or throwing up looking at
me um
they took me to the hospital i was
hospitalized for about i think it's
three good three months second time you
narrowly escaped that yeah that's the
second time yeah the second time there
was way more this way i mean i've
probably been through it about at least
50 times
and uh it's not a good feeling you know
i don't recommend it but i'll tell you
one thing it does it does something to
people
i'm gonna say it builds a warrior but
it'll make you a little bit
have an edge on a normal normal person
you know what i'm saying
like as i walk around i try to like
feel that i'm the man around where i'm
at because you know at the end of the
day out here
and where we're from out here you know
skid row and everything any kind of
weakness they eat up and they will
murder you i'm pretty sure you've heard
it or heard of it yeah yeah
um i stay right here a couple blocks i
stayed on these streets before um i'm
addicted to fentanyl you know
um
i did good for i did a seven year
stretch
in prison um
when i got out i tried to do good so i i
actually did for
i got sober for about five years in my
life you know i had a wife a
kid um
eventually relapsed
you know
which that was the best thing that ever
happened to me my kids was the best
thing that ever happened to me i mean
i actually felt like i was living life
for once you know legitly
um
but uh what you know slowly but surely
me and my wife started partying with
drugs i told her i had an issue with it
she's like we'll take let's take acid
and other things you know things that
you don't really have issues with so
it started there you know it it spiraled
real quick because i have an addictive
personality and my mom was a dopey my
dad was a doping you know what i'm
saying
um the rest of them are alcoholics
there's i don't have a one normal family
member
they're all grown up from watts compton
you know
um
so basically
[Music]
i
tried to do the best i could you know it
was it was real hard
with the things i had to work with you
know what i'm saying
um
i had one good thing in my life was
which was my step dad uh he was his name
is lester o'malley he's a
he's a marine he started as a
in the navy
he's a marine corps you know marine
background
so i always wanted to make my dad happy
so i'd try to be yes or no sir around my
house and um
when i wanted to do my thing i would
use the skills he probably pretty much
taught me
you know
because my i was actually let's go back
a little bit i was a boy scout too my
dad had me as a boy scout believe it or
not
and um so he was making it he was really
creating a little soldier because his
dad was in the military i was i wanted
to be military you know
so i i think part of the reason i did
the gang thing is he had me
you know toughing me up
i was shooting rifles at the age of nine
you know
um
he was pretty much building a soldier
and uh
then when my mom took me from him took
me to this place all that things
everything he taught me i just
first people i met that were with that
were these hoolans you know what i'm
saying
and uh you know johnny casper
he's from my area johnny casper was
actually a connected person yeah at a
time right i'm from the southeast he's
he's from a cigar yeah i'm from brown
brotherhood we're kicked up
actually yeah at one point he was
not he was he was up there nine years he
was the man pretty much um
and since our neighbors are like this
you know it just so happens that all our
neighborhoods out there in whittier
gym town and cr and his game
we all have family members from the same
neighborhood so we kind of stayed
together you know what i'm saying yeah
um
our games were actually started by
vietnam veterans too i don't know if you
people understand yeah it's different
than the rest of the gangs where so we
have a you know we have a strict
they want us to be respectful and and
kind of kill the bad guy gangsters is
what they're after you know i'm saying
but um yeah johnny casper he was a he
was a big uh big deal dude johnny's my
bud
you know have you seen it he's out here
now huh he's he's he's probably done a
dozen
of these talks on my channel
yeah the dude let me tell you to do to
somebody
i i couldn't believe when i seen him it
really shocked me to see him out here
like that um
he's a little older than me so
growing up where he's from
uh we're from the southeast on that's
southeast of l.a so basically it's like
um
or not it starts in downey peak or
rivera where you got um
what what else is it it's um
not oc it's right next to la merada you
know you got um hawaiian guardians
well it's a whole different place a
whole different
you don't see like out here you see
homeless people walking around [ __ ]
in the street and [ __ ] like that we
don't have we don't we don't let that
out there yeah
you know like people like that
we get them and for the most part
a lot of these dudes out here wouldn't
be standing if the gang remembers are
still out trust me
which
i don't know i don't know a lot of
people have an issue with them but these
are the bullying ones we're talking
about you know i was taught to protect
the neighborhood and uh be for be there
for people and and take care of the
bullies you know honestly
it's a whole different thing you know
you got people like
i can't name certain certain gang you
know but there's people that have been
greenlighted and people that haven't you
know what i'm saying
but uh johnny casper yeah he ran the
show out there so
yeah dude i can't believe that he's even
out here the dude was he was making
money dude money
and he was pretty much shot calling from
pretty high up bro
and um
yeah basically that uh i got my i got my
life together like i said i met this
girl
um i had two beautiful daughters with
her this is recent
this is after all that you know
she got me away from my gang
which was kind of cool but in the same
sense her brother was from my worst
enemies
so when i moved into her house i kind of
had an issue over there too with that
you know what i'm saying
but uh
yeah so i move in the girl treated she
was the most beautiful wonderful girl
she actually changed my life for me for
a little bit
but um
you know i am a drug addict and
eventually i went back to the way
um
my old ways and started partying you
know
at first i tried to hide it from her but
you know she would be like dude you're
acting crazy when we have sex
you know the one time we're having sex
she started crying she's like what the
hell is wrong with you
and i because i was just always into it
and i was choking or slapping her
because i was on meth you know and
she told me she's like you're on meth
again dude she's like dude
don't do it you know i mean you're gonna
ruin what we have you know like i was
working two jobs doing good i had a
family going right
started doing meth not even a month
later dude everything went to [ __ ] lost
my job
um
started putting my hands on my x-ray
thinking she was cheating on me because
she meant she wasn't you know it was the
meth and the paranoia
um
then my uh
my grandma died the one who adopted me
and once she died i really lost it i
felt like i had no meaning in life no no
reason to live you know um
my brother at the same time
was my best friend uh i don't talk to no
other my family so my brother was there
for we're there for each other
um he lost his mind
someone smoked him out with a pcp and he
lost his mind right
so my mom gave up on him he was in a
psych ward for two years he didn't know
who was who
you know what i'm saying
um
and
pretty much i threw everything down the
drain from for that it my mom's death
and my brother i couldn't take it so i
started went back to my gang and
doing things that i thought i knew would
make me feel better which were drugs and
all that you know what i'm saying
and um
since then i've pretty much lost
everything i have nothing no more
um totally
i am
i know i look kind of young you know but
i'm 41.
i'm 41. i started doing things like that
at age 11. i had really no role model my
like i said my mom who adopted me was an
alcoholic so as long as i was out of her
hair she really didn't care what i was
doing so
um
i grabbed her towards the gang members
and it felt like a family they actually
loved me you know
they would never let me die you know
what i'm saying i mean they would we try
hardest not to let each other die you
know what i'm saying
and uh
which i thought was the right decision
but looking back at it now you know i've
done 16 years in the system
i'm back here
homeless which is uh
other places ain't that bad but out here
in skid row and you know people lose
their life every day
um
see a lot of girls come out here normal
and get flipped over prostitutes they
really don't care they end up dying out
here
i have out of the 60 people i know i
probably lost
50 of them
you know
um
it seemed like an ongoing cycle you know
i
i have two daughters right now that are
depending on me i i can't get my head
out of this though it's like
i go i've been there and i've done that
for them and i i felt like you know
basically like
it wasn't enough ever
so
basically i relapsed and i came back out
here and i'm struggling to stay alive
out here bro
i shoot
i shoot phenomenal
mostly people smoke it i shoot it i
shoot about a gram and a half
which is a lot
um
i do it by myself you know i don't want
to be a burner on nobody if i ever die
so uh
yeah i've been pushing my limbs out here
and uh
pretty much i'm to the point right now
where it's either
i get my focus on and try to
get a hold of myself finally
or i have a good feeling i'll be dead
within the next couple of years dude
from doing what i'm doing over and over
you get me yeah but because you're so
i'm so yeah you're so your body is so
conditioned yes i mean the fentanyl that
it's going to be hard for you to od now
is that's that's part of it and you're
you're the other part of yours
more and more and more so it is pushing
the limit now
i'm not saying it's a good thing i'm
just
yeah
you're not like
a crack addict who gets exposed to
fentanyl diets oh they're done oh no
they're dead
you're you're a fentanyl addict who
can't yeah
i'm a phenomenal addict that that
you could ask out here 80 second role
they can't even not do a shot with me
they will die yeah
so basically if i don't have what i need
you're hardcore yeah
so
i go to bed at night even if i fix when
i go to bed hard
as i wake up in the morning i'm already
throwing up sweaty i i'm
anxiety through the roof i cannot
cannot talk to anybody unless i'm i get
my eye you know
which
i i go through any means necessary to
get it you know i just i just i have
limits of
messing with people that i don't think
deserve it you understand
so i try to mess with the other gang
members and stuff robin
you know
um
but i do have some type of morals you
know what i'm saying out of all this i i
don't
believe in hitting women and all that so
i try to if i see a girl getting beat
i'll try to you know
help him or do what i have to do but um
seriously if i could
go to the military right now i guarantee
i would
you know the only two times i've kicked
my this drug out of
what 20 something years now
it i kick it in jail the only way i'll
keep with the kick the drug they have to
put you know put me in jail
which is the worst you know you gotta
they don't give you nothing in there so
you just crawl the walls and
um
raise them grisly kick it and every time
i kick it i mean they're like dude i got
my fresh brain back and i'm like man
when i get out i'm gonna do good
i promise you mom my mom everybody is
dead i promise i've got this one dude
i'm in there i feel so confident dude as
soon as they open those doors for me
brother
i get this feeling in my stomach that
like you know
i just throw it like it's so easy for me
to say you know what [ __ ] it dude i'm
going back i'm getting high and i'm
going to do this [ __ ] again really
and i do this i got i'm almost 100
percent like it's like what is that all
about
i hope you see it's just it's so easy
that's your opportunity to get clean and
get your life straight
and put your life back together
i know
it's just so hard to
with all the things i've been through i
i this is my excuse like i call it my
excuse with all the things i've been
through i just feel like it's so [ __ ]
hard dude
to get people to look at me normal
or accept my normality so they always
think i'm up to no good anyway
um
i'm a really loyal person to people so
when i see i feel like people cross my
back
i'm really
um
i take things to heart you know what i'm
saying and and usually what i want to do
after that is i want to
pretty much just
leave them
so i'm not a burden to anybody and i i
try to like
drown my misery with drugs dude like
i'm talking a lot dude my habit right
now is like i do ground shots of phenol
which if you ask anybody it's this
doctors don't believe me
i'm to the point where those barely give
me well for a good like 10 minutes
you know what i'm saying
um
i smoke uh pcp
basically anything i get my hands on
just to keep my just to keep myself
down to earth you know what i'm saying
um
but like i said it runs in my family my
sister my brother everybody they're all
dope fiends
my mom my dad sorry to say we're dope
fiends
um my dad was shot by the cops when i
was uh what nine years old
i witnessed that um
my mom finally got out of jail when i
was 16 so she did 16 years straight your
dad died he died uh it wasn't the
articles you got shot at um if you go to
southgate there's a park called tweety
park
there's only been three cop murders
there one is my dad he has the same name
as me his name is pablo
i'm paul but pablo in spanish you know
pablo ramirez you could like it you know
look it up you'll see it he was uh
he was up there from the
you know i'm going to say
the names but you know
i say the southern mafia people you know
he's from
florence florencia
i don't know if you heard of it
notorious gang victoria's gang yeah
they're worldwide yeah
uh
my dad's really known from there um i've
been told when i went to prison hey mule
just let them know your dad is when you
get on the yard and you know you have a
little better
it's like downey is there
uh where isn't aren't they based in
downey where
oh
no they're based everywhere brother yeah
yeah yeah downies their their latest one
they have a clicking down i'm sorry they
have a click and downey um they
originated though and um
in huntington park
hp that's where my family's from they're
from like 86th street and hp right there
um
my dad had seven brothers they're all
from florence
they're from the one of the first
cliques from florence so they're pretty
known my grappler was from there
my grandpa's name oh bully
friends in the family yes yeah no choice
yeah pretty much i did we'll see it
they're all from florence but i end up
getting from a different game because
that's where my heart was you know i
didn't live my mom like i said my mom
pulled me from that area trying to
take me to a better place you get me
and what she did she didn't she didn't
know where her wouldn't be that bad but
you know back in those days uh people
don't really know but they just call it
it was really racist back then it was
called white ear oh is that right yeah
right because my step dad his name is
lester lester earl manley he's actually
born and raised up there with his
parents and um
so you know he tells me which i pretty
much i mean he he raised me
to have some type of kind of goals and
standards for myself you know i'm saying
because he's military
so you know i'd go home and
be yes or no sir
and as soon as i leave i'd be a whole
different person you know i and i kept
that up my whole life for my until one
day he found out
and he pretty much you know
beat my ass and told me i was a little
life punk kid
pretty much yeah i was driving with him
in his truck we were going he barely got
back from camp
we were going to get some dinner you
know he was a real
as i call a real real good strong
american man
you know and so we're going for dinner
as we're going
he noticed there was a kid next to me
staring at me with a bald head like mine
so as soon as my dog my dad wasn't
paying attention i started mad dogging
him actually you know i boom something
hit me i turned around my dad he's like
what the [ __ ] giving my kid mad dog
faces for
you little hoodlum now a little punk you
know what i mean
he's all you know i taught you better
than that you know what i'm saying my
because low-key my dad is kind of racist
i mean even though he adopted two
mexican kids he was still kind of racist
but morgan's you know
um
he's the driving iron and and tell me
something see these people were here i
mean it was crazy i see people taking
shits in the middle of the street
he's like this is this is the pretty
much the
hells of earth and um
all these people these colors can you
see like other skin cells you say
they'll take your life in an instant for
pennies in your pocket
so don't believe these monkeys you know
you you try to raise me in a racist
form you know
which didn't work out because you know
right where we moved to there i had
actually had a couple friends that were
black you know
so um
basically
that's it i mean i've
done over 15 years in prison
uh i shoot ben all my neck
oh you see it yeah
um
i've been chasing it i have two
daughters right now growing up without
me which you know makes me sad and
i hope
i could get a hold of myself one of
these days before i die you know
i'm lucky to be alive though i really am
and i i want to be able to give them
something or leave them with something
you know i want to eventually get my
ways a little different
but uh you know a lot of people use
excuses of their past to do drugs and
the reason they're on drugs you know i
mean
um i'm getting older to the point where
i just understand that it's just
you you gotta
you gotta challenge ahead of you because
fentanyl is a tough it's a tough one
yeah plus i um
i think i have liver failure right now
and kidney failure because i i have
pepsi
i got hep c out here
um
recently about a month ago they just
called my wife my ex-wife actually and
they told her to tell me to rush to the
uh to the emergency room
because there's something really wrong
with my
my liver
so i think i'm getting this roasted the
liver
i can't make to the doctors because i
don't have enough dope ever to make it
to the doctor do you understand
um the first time i went like
i almost died because it was this right
here what was that
that's a basically it was an abscess
that i got but it wasn't from a miss it
was from speed
dirty speed
i suppose speed on my in my uh fennel
i shot it
um felt everything was fine
next day
my arm had to be the size of my leg it
was swelling up was infected
i was catching a fever
within four days after that dude i could
not walk
this thing was i don't know what was
going on but my friends were begging me
to go to the hospital and i'm like dude
no
am i gonna be sick in the hospital plus
this yes
some of the people i've interviewed that
have medical issues
they don't i see the comments because
people won't understand why doesn't this
person go to the doctor that's exactly
why right yeah because they don't help
us with
your addiction their addiction and with
if you don't they don't want to go cold
turkey
in the in the hospital yeah it's the
worst that's why they don't go to the
doctor
i swear to god i've been in i've been
i've been in a lot of pain and a lot of
i've done a lot of broken bones and
being sick on this drug
it's almost like
it has to be the worst thing i would not
wish it on my enemies dude
first you feel like you're gonna [ __ ]
you you can't control your your emotions
they're
all over the place dude your anxiety
goes through the wolf the roof i mean
um
basically at that point you're willing
to do whatever you have to do to get
your drug you know what i'm saying um
[Music]
it's it's just i i can't explain it's
just
the sickness you get you i've literally
felt like like i was dying like i would
ask somebody to shoot me at that moment
um
that that that i mean that part of the
cake lasts with phenol that's for about
10 days
it took me 40 41 days to kick completely
the first the first time i did
for 31 days brother
you're so exhausted
so exhausted mentally physically
emotionally
and you want to sleep but you cannot
sleep for the life of you because you're
sick
so
um
i mean i was tossing and turning like a
alligator and then at the time this
happened i was i got caught for a
warrant for one of my warrants
so i was kicking in jail you know
i'm a south sider so we have rules you
can't be
you know complaining
acting like that you got to have respect
whatever you do you can't throw up in
front of people there's a bunch of rules
you know what i'm saying
you know but when you're coming down
like that you don't care about the rules
you know
so there's been a couple times where i
had to get blue blocked you know
because i was just like i give a [ __ ]
right now dude like you know i'd rather
take the beating
and [ __ ] about it
you know what i'm saying um
[Music]
but um
yeah so when you're kicking it's just
too much that i mean for 30 days i
couldn't sleep i was cramping up
at those moments you go through
emotional like breakdowns where you want
to like
say this is this is it like dude i could
do it this time you know what i mean
i must have said that to myself about 50
times
you know and um
yeah you try your hardest you to to flip
your mind state
and you are you're in a good mind state
as long as you're not doing drugs in
there
your mind's pretty sharp so like i think
those decisions you're going through if
you were to follow through when you go
out you might be able to change your
life you know
but for me i just think that addiction
is just like i just i always had
addiction addictive personality i just
feel like my addiction is so bad that
i want that badly
because i have daughters like i said but
as soon as i step out and i'm free
the first thing i do dude no matter what
every [ __ ] time it had to be over 50
times i've done this
i go straight to the [ __ ]
skid row
running somebody i know and i get my fix
on dude
it seems like every time that happens i
overdose i overdose about 10 times
it's always the first time i come back
and you do some jail time a lot of
people die like this they're usually
when they die from either getting shot
or are are you know dying because they
thought they could handle the strategy
because they are clean in jail so the
last time i got out my friend uh
luckily i was one of my friends um
told her give me a little shot i thought
i could handle it it was tiny tiny tiny
i did it i remember feeling it
feeling pins needles i'm like whoa [ __ ]
yeah right and then i don't remember
nothing bro
all i remember is waking up and um
i thought i was having sex because this
girl had fully mounted me and she was i
felt like she was kissing me
she was giving me mouth-to-mouth bro
come to find out
so i wake up and i giggle
and i smile at her i'm like whoa what's
up and she's like dude she's like dude
you almost died she's like she's crying
hysterically she's like we gave you five
of those
narcans and no movement dude you saw
dude i started giving you cpr
her name sylvia is my other friend um
i don't know how you met sylvia
we all stayed around here for a while
i've interviewed samantha and
cheese probably more than one one of
each you don't know my friend chase
chase two yeah he's another one he
hasn't he's been through a lot too yeah
he's missing his arm miss yeah yeah
and uh he can he comes from a nice part
of town though we know this yeah i know
we don't see people
i think and uh
so basically um you know
right now i'm at the point where i'm
trying to cut down i want to try to get
a hold of myself again
i'm not a religious person um
i believe there's a higher power
and i i but i really believe in karma
so um
you know i actually
have some type of standards for being a
doping i don't i don't do drugs in the
streets i don't like kids see it
you know i don't condone to kids you
know what i'm saying
and if i see someone doing it i will i
will do something about it
um
yeah this is not for for i hope this
drug doesn't you know go too too much
longer
but um
that is it's taking people out like
crazy
you know
i don't know if you know but it's it's
it's it's a killer
it's it's uh supposed to be like 100
times stronger than heroin death wish
huh you think you have a death wish
i do
i've had one dude
i've had one like i said i would i was
born
into a pretty [ __ ] up situation so
you know uh
[ __ ] i missed this you know my uncle my
uncle tried to rape me when i was 13.
yeah
which he was a dope fiend too
which happened down here too and he
brought me to a motel down here and said
we're just gonna get high because you
know i was about 16 17 and i was getting
high on crack he found out
actually like my uncle we used to get
high all the time so this time was a
little different you know he
you know let's get him will tell us we
don't have to be all paranoid this man
all right uncle that's cool you know i
never would never thought you know
and we get to the to the motel you know
and
he just started acting different you
know his first question was if i was hot
it was summer time so i was you know
take off your shirt you know
just you know be comfortable you don't
have to be you know we're good right
here you know just don't say anything
these wrists are your mind your family
member nothing did all this our family
know about this
so we're from there to like you know
damn you know you're kind of sexy you
know it's my uncle time in this [ __ ] you
know i'm like wait a minute
what do you mean
yeah whatever uncle you know
let me tell you i wasn't i was a pretty
stocky kid you know mike a little
smarter than me so i just like whatever
i threw it through by
so he started water he started coming
back to me and i bought my back sore and
i started feeling weird you know nervous
i was like wait a minute this is the
scene
and he he looked at me and he just
pulled his pants down you know he's like
you want to suck my dick
i just i looked at him i'm like dude
you're my uncle dude are you [ __ ]
kidding me right now bro
i don't know what to do really i was
scared you know
but you know my reaction was like dude
in my head i'm like [ __ ] this dude
he's not making me do this and i'm
saying so basically
he pulled his pants off he asked me to
sit next to him he said it's all right
i was like uncle didn't
i'm 16 years old dude
i'm all you know my story uncle you know
i had another uncle of mine he was on
meth and he was gay he tried to rape me
too
well he had his dick
here
he asked me what i thought about it you
know and
like i told him when i tried to tear it
off was
it's doing nothing for me so obviously
put the [ __ ] away uncle and i'm like
that's not me uncle
and he pretty much beat me up and try to
rape me mom and uncle this is let me
tell you this is that his brother did
this to me
who i thought i could trust there are
because a lot of them were did 20 30
years in prison to them this is normal
you know what i'm saying yeah
so but to do with your own family memory
i would have never thought
basically
i got up and i ran out he chased me
through downtown
i didn't want me to tell my parents
which i had said [ __ ] this i went and
told on him which was a good thing
because he was been lasting his own son
and child is he had two sons of his own
who since birth were hiding in the
mother station
um you know
just molesting them their whole life so
basically since me bringing that out
they actually stood up for themselves
um he moved because we hit the rest of
the family tried to kill them
and uh basically um
yeah that was that was the first time so
you know
i've been through a lot dude yeah been
through life you know it's been a tough
road but it's a crazy life
it is dude it is but you know i i
the little the little life that i did
get to experience with trying to have my
own job and you know for that little bit
man it felt good bro
it felt good that was the best time of
your life best time in my life i was
going clean you had your kids i was
clean i had kids i mean i was smoking
weed but i was doing the hard stuff you
know
um
we raised not only
see when i met my ex she had already
when i met her she had barely had a baby
so he was three months
her her boyfriend got her pregnant she
was 16 years old let me tell you
i was 24 years old we lied to each other
when we met i twitter i was 21 and she
said she was 22.
it was crazy we didn't find out so two
years later our real ages
so basically anyway so
i met her and she ate
tried to scare me out of you know
she was kind of my house will smoke a
black you know so i go to her house i'm
in love with her she's real pretty she's
but she's not
draggy you know all she did was smoke
weed and she's like a metalhead girl she
like rock and roll real pretty woman
so basically i go there and uh
hang out smoke weed i was high in the
fact i was on meth and other things and
i was from a gang hit it all um
yeah so she opens the door there's a
trippy part she opens the door
she's holding
four kids in her arms
she's like before we uh you know get to
know each other which one you know these
are my kids and i'm just like
what the [ __ ] how old are you dude she's
like i'm 22. i'm like dude
wow
so it kind of made me think oh wait a
minute
you know she's been hiding she's had her
legs open for lottery she has [ __ ]
four kids dude the oldest one was like
six years old i'm like how old are you
girl you know what i'm saying
so anyway
come to find out that was the test she
wanted to see where i was at you know
um i didn't run so we kicked it blaze i
didn't try to be father of these kids
but i was nice to him obviously because
i have nieces and nephews and i've been
through what i've been through
so um
come to find out those were her
brother's kids because he was from like
my rival gang southside whittier
he got caught he hadn't didn't have his
green paint because green uh was it his
paperwork
he's a legal citizen
so they deported him
so
my ex that's why i think she's such a
wonderful woman she raised
his three kids plus her son which caught
into being my like my son
um well
at the when he turned three we she got
pregnant with my daughter
we ended up having two more daughters
right i'm sober though at the time i'm
working two jobs you know
she can't work because she's not an
illegal citizen she's been here since
she was little but they won't give her
paperwork
so basically um
we struggled pretty hard but we
bought a pad that her mom stays in now
this is the only time i've ever done my
whole life brother the only time it was
a good like six year streak i was
working for a paint store
i was doing uh
joining the union you know going to
school working two jobs and then i was
making wax you know waxes weed wax
yeah
so i was making wax and selling into the
the the because this one the the medical
clinics concentrated uh thc yeah this is
when they first started coming out i'm
going to concentrate so i got into that
with my neighbor wesley and he was
pretty big you know
so life was good man life was good we
were always we always had our kids with
this you know all five of them
um
we were there for him all that like i
said dude one day my girl wanted a party
she could bust out the cocaine it was
the worst thing she ever did
i would have you know addictive
personality so once that was once the
cocaine was there and it left there was
no more to get i went back to the meth
from the myth i went back to the heroine
and here you are and here i am dude it's
been i've been out here for now six
years
trying to trying to get trying to get
right
you know
i try to give them money and whenever i
can and see my daughters you know
but they're growing like this bro
and and i hope and i just don't i i i'm
i'm trying to get ahold of myself for
the best of me
because i feel like either in the next
couple years i'm going to die or i get a
hold of myself you've been clean before
you know what it went through called
turkey
yeah
that's fennel if i was keen
on meth pcp
uh xanax and you kicked him he kicked
all that dude it was worse he was so bad
bro it's got to be hard
hard but as men we should be able to go
through and do what we got i mean i pull
myself there i should be able to take it
you know
but um pretty much
that's pretty much it you know all right
pablo thank you so much for all right
sharing your story hope you liked it
brother it was very interesting thank
you brother
you